Video playing international
masterstr
in no
idea
Nation
guy so
French
jaicenck
in
mat
Championship
winner F6
wi
interesting
interting
may mat
Championship
en the
games
so defend the time all the
so
hcrificed not so clear
compation
okayle
how work
E4 play E4
here yes okay rooky
F also takes maybe
playing maybe
playing F3 against
that not really
yes
trying Queen
F7
F6
castles yes actually that was the best
way
play
okay need
PIN
developing
piece das
G5 good
thing not behind
development
maybe Queen F7 was okay after don't
sacrifice
working
objectively
BL
work
obiece okay so A3
maybe take
here maybe King
F8
yes
honest
working really not sound
sacrifice K F6
CD5 C Bishop C4 tricky
okay let move the king out
the now the Rook is really attacked
takes on D5 take on
D4 Proba needs to  take on C6
now
okay so Bishop C5
now yes I don't want to have SP to
worry
about
here h maybe B3 or
something yes yes I was I was pretty sure
that something better but king8 maybe
maybe wasn't so
great gives him  some some
compensation
rook76 Check
got Queen D5
here got Queen
D5
unbelev
yes
game
bish7 Queen
Queen okay
go
check
Check yes now
easy6
indefensible
yes
dispp
F6
yes mention was winning
Prob
move already
Bad Check
loses
yes
whatever
P
after
Bl
okay thanks for
watching